COME TO ORDER. WE NEARLY HAVE A
QUORUM. IF WE GET ONE MORE
SENATOR, ONE MORE SENATOR, WE
WILL HAVE A QUORUM. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WE'RE HOLDING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM 2100
OF THE Ó STREET BUILDING. I ASK
THAT ALL MEMBERS PRESENT
THEMSELVES IN ROOM 2100. SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE JUST
NEED ONE MORE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RAMOS IS HERE, READY TO PRESENT
HIS BILL. WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL.
SO, I WANT TO NOTE THAT FOR THIS
BILL AND FOR ALL OTHER BILLS IN
THE FUTURE, WE'LL ALLOW TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. EACH PRIMARY WITNESS
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK
AFTER THE PRIMARY SUPPORT, I'LL
INVITE OTHER SUPPORTERS TO STATE
THEIR NAME, THEIR AFFILIATION,
AND THEIR POSITION, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. I'LL
DO THE SAME FOR THE OPPOSITION.
AFTER WE HEAR FROM SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION, WE'LL TURN TO THE
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IF YOU WISH TO FURTHER EXPOUND
UPON YOUR POSITION, YOU CAN
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE
USING ONE OF THE METHODS
DESCRIBED IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA, AB 81.
WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE, YES. SENATOR WILK
HAS WHAT YOU WANT TO KNOW,
BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
ALL YEAR WHERE THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE ACTUALLY TURNED OUT EARLY
IN. SO BETTER ATTENDANCE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR WILK.
SENATOR WILK HAS NOTED THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME IN MY FOUR
YEARS HOW MANY YEARS? 4 OR 5
YEARS OF BEING CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE, THAT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY SHOWED UP IN
GREATER PROPORTION THAN THE
REPUBLICANS EARLY ON. SO THANK
YOU, SENATOR WILK, FOR POINTING
THAT OUT. ALL RIGHT. YOU ARE
FAIR. ALL RIGHT, SO WE HAVE AB
81 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS,
WHICH WE'RE HEARING PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 29.10 SUB B. ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS,
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE HERE.
SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIRMAN. SENATORS
TODAY DEALING WITH AN ISSUE
CALLED ICWA DEALS WITH A RARE
REVERSE ASSIMILATION POLICY THAT
DEALS WITH MAKING SURE THAT THAT
INDIAN CHILDREN GO WITH INDIAN
FAMILIES TO LEARN. RAMOS, BEFORE
YOU GET TOO FAR INTO THIS THING,
I APOLOGIZE, BUT I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BECAUSE WE
HAVE TWO OTHER COMMITTEES GOING
ON IN THE SENATE RIGHT NOW. SO
IF YOU DON'T MIND IF WE'LL JUST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, YOU CAN
PRESENT TO THE TO THE FULL
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
UMBERG HERE. UMBERG HERE. WILK
PRESENT. WILK PRESENT. ALAN
ASHBY HERE. ASHBY. HERE
CABALLERO. DURAZO DURAZO HERE.
LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD. HERE NILO
ROTH. STERN. STERN. HERE WAHAB,
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU. SILVERMAN.
RAMOS. GO AHEAD. SORRY TO
INTERRUPT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. AND SENATORS, INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT IS A RARE
REVERSE ASSIMILATION POLICY THAT
LOOKS TO PUT INDIAN CHILDREN
BACK WITH THEIR CULTURAL
FAMILIES, TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
THE CULTURE ALIVE, SOMETHING
THAT WAS STRIPPED THROUGHOUT
HISTORY, ICWA CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A BEACON OF HOPE FOR
INDIAN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES. AND IN SO THE
SUPREME COURT, U.S. SUPREME
COURT UPHELD THE RIGHTS OF
INDIAN PEOPLE THROUGH ICWA.
TODAY, I AM PRESENTING AB 81, A
BILL THAT DEALS WITH THIS
POLICY. I WANT TO FIRST THANK
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL OVER
THIS SESSION, AND I AM HAPPY TO
BE IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
PRESENTING THIS BILL. ICWA WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 1978 AND IS A
FEDERAL LAW THAT ESTABLISHES
MINIMUM FEDERAL STANDARDS FOR
STATE COURT CHILD WELFARE
PROCEEDINGS AND ANY CHILD
CUSTODY PROCEEDINGS INVOLVING
INDIAN CHILDREN. AB 81 WOULD
CODIFY SECTIONS OF THE FEDERAL
LAW INTO CALIFORNIA'S ICWA LAW,
STRENGTHENING PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA INDIAN CHILDREN. LAST
YEAR, THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT VOTED 7 TO 2 TO REJECT THE
CHALLENGE OF ICWA. THERE WAS A
CHALLENGE THAT TOOK ON CALLED
HOLLAND AND BRACKEN, AND THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT SIDED WITH
INDIAN CHILDREN. THIS IS A MAJOR
VICTORY FOR TRIBAL NATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE FUTURE OF
TRIBAL CULTURES. THE DECISION
AFFIRMS WHAT TRIBAL NATIONS HAVE
LONG KNOWN. ICWA IS THE BEST
PRACTICE IN CHILD WELFARE, AND
DESERVES TO BE UPHELD IN THE
UNITED STATES AND IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE THE SUPREME
COURT REJECTED ALL CLAIMS
AGAINST ICWA, THERE ARE SPACES
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN ADDRESS AND
UPDATE TO SHIELD CALIFORNIA
TRIBES AGAINST FUTURE
CHALLENGES. THIS BILL WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE LAWS SURROUNDING
INDIAN CHILD CUSTODY AND
PROCEEDINGS PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CHERI TRIPA, CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
HABBO HOTEL POMO OF UPPER LAKE
AND BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL FAMILIES
COALITION, A SPONSOR ALSO IS
SCOTT GOVERNOR, REPRESENTING THE
MORONGO TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS. ALL RIGHT. FIRST WITNESS,
PLEASE APPROACH. MICROPHONE YES.
RIGHT THERE. IT'S FINE. GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS SHERRY TREPA. I SPENT
THE LAST 20 YEARS AS THE
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL PERSON FOR
HABEMATOLEL POMO OF UPPER LAKE.
IN THE LAST 16 YEARS AS THE
CHAIRWOMAN. TODAY, I REPRESENT
MY TRIBE AS THE TRIBAL
AMBASSADOR, WORKING ON
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS. AND I'M
PRESIDENT OF OUR ENTERPRISE C .
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY TRIBE AND
MY PERSONAL SUPPORT FOR AB 81,
AND HOPE THAT YOU ALL WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TO HABEMATOLEL
POMO OF UPPER LAKE HAS LONG BEEN
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL FAMILIES COALITION. THE
ORGANIZATION CO-SPONSORING THE
BILL ALONG WITH THE MORONGO BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS CALIFORNIA,
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST STATES IN
THE NATION TO ENACT STATE ICWA
LEGISLATION OVER 15 YEARS AGO.
WHILE I AM PROUD OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR STATE HAS HAD
IN THE AREA, WE CANNOT REST ON
THESE PAST ACHIEVEMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST LAWS
AND POLICIES IN PLACE TO PROTECT
TRIBES AND THEIR CITIZENS AND
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEMS, WE MUST
CONSTANTLY MOVE FORWARD. AB 81
MAKES MUCH NEEDED UPDATES TO
CALIFORNIA LAWS RELATED TO ICWA
PROTECTIONS. THE BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN THE ROLE OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY IN CASES RELATED TO
INDIAN CHILDREN AND FAMILIES,
AND TO PREVENT AGAINST FUTURE
ATTACKS ON THE FEDERAL ICWA. IT
WILL ALSO REAFFIRM ICWA
PROTECTIONS, APPLY TO ALL INDIAN
CHILDREN, REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY
COME INTO CONTACT WITH THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. IT WILL ALSO
ENSURE THE PLACEMENTS ARE FOUND
WITHIN THE KIN FIRST MODEL OF
ICWA PLACEMENT PREFERENCES, SO
THAT KIDS STAY AS CLOSE TO HOME
AND TO THEIR COMMUNITY AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE BURDEN
SHIFTING TO TRIBES IN STATE
COURT CASES. AND FINALLY, IT
AUTHORIZES TRIBES TO ASSESS AND
APPROVE EMERGENCY FOSTER HOMES
FOR INDIAN CHILDREN. AS YOU
LIKELY KNOW, THE SUPREME COURT
UPHELD THE FEDERAL ICWA WITH
MONUMENTAL WIN FOR TRIBES IN THE
HOLLAND V BRACKEEN CASE LAST
JUNE. BECAUSE OF THIS, AB 81
DOES NOT HAVE TO BE A HEAVY LIFT
WITH BIG CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATUTORY STRUCTURE.
INSTEAD, WE NEED LANGUAGE THAT
IS BIPARTISAN AND INTENDED TO
CLARIFY AND STRENGTHEN OUR
CURRENT STATUTORY PROTECTION.
THANK YOU. IF YOU'D WRAP IT UP,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. WELL, I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT WITNESS, MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. SCOTT. GOVERNOR,
ON BEHALF OF THE MORONGO BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS, A CO-SPONSOR.
I'LL TRY NOT TO BE REDUNDANT
HERE. THIS IS REALLY A CLEANUP
BILL. IT WAS REFERENCED THROUGH
OVER 30 CODE SECTIONS
DIFFERENTLY THROUGHOUT. THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE
UNIFORMITY. SO SHOULD ANOTHER
LEGAL CHALLENGE ARISE.
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE WELL
POSITIONED TO PROTECT TRIBAL
CHILDREN AND KEEP THE LAW
INTACT. THAT'S THE GOAL OF THE
MEASURE. AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MR. GOVERNOR. ALL
RIGHT. ALL THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, PLEASE GIVE
US YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, PAULA
TRIBE, ON BEHALF OF PECHANGA,
TEJON AND THE COLUSA TRIBES,
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHINITO.
TULE RIVER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. FRANK MOLINA,
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN MANUEL BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS, THE SANTA
YNEZ BAND OF MISSION INDIANS,
AND THE SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF
MIWOK INDIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, DAVID QUINTANA.
ON BEHALF OF THE BAND OF
KUMEYAAY INDIANS, THE CAHUILLA
BAND OF INDIANS, AND THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA OF CHUKCHANSI
INDIANS. THANK YOU, CHAIR
MEMBERS TIFFANY PHªN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION, OR
CALCASA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANDREW. GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF
SUNIGA, THE CALIFORNIA NATIONS
INDIAN GAMING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS KRISTIN POWELL WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, PAM
LOPEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIA TRIBE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING, LET'S
NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 81, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S TURN TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SENATOR ASHBY
AND THEN SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. HELLO IN MY TIME
PRIOR TO BEING A LEGISLATOR, I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON
ICWA. QUITE A BIT IN THE INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT WITH MY DAD,
WHO WAS THE HEAD OF FOSTER CARE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
THINK THIS IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AREA OF THE LAW, ONE
THAT OFTEN GETS OVERLOOKED IN
FACT, A LOT OF PEOPLE,
WELL-MEANING, DO WORK IN THE
FOSTER CARE ADOPTIONS AREA AND
OVERLOOK THE IMPLICATIONS OF
ICWA. AND YOU SEE A LOT OF
CLEANUP LEGISLATION HERE
ACTUALLY GOING BACK AND JUST
FIXING THE ICWA PIECE THAT WAS
INADVERTENTLY MISSED SOMETIMES
BY LEGISLATORS. THERE WAS A
MOMENT, PROBABLY ABOUT EIGHT
MONTHS AGO, WHERE THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE BEEN CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT JUST TO PROTECT ICWA
IN CALIFORNIA HAD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GONE A DIFFERENT WAY
AND YOU WERE WILLING TO CARRY
IT, EVEN THEN, AND TO STAND UP
FOR THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
PACKAGE. AND I WAS PREPARED EVEN
THEN TO HAVE YOUR BACK. NOW IT
IS A MUCH LIGHTER LIFT AS SOME
FOLKS HAVE INDICATED HERE, BUT I
WOULD ARGUE EQUALLY IMPORTANT,
WE DON'T WANT TO RELY ON FEDERAL
DECISIONS. WE WANT CALIFORNIA TO
PROTECT THE KIDS AND THE TRIBES
AND THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
DOES THAT. AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IT TODAY BECAUSE FOR ALL
THE LEGISLATORS WHO ARE HERE,
WHEN YOU'RE VOTING ON THESE
BILLS EVER IN THE FUTURE,
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH CHILD
WELFARE, JUST LOOK REALLY QUICK
TO SEE IF THE BILL ADDRESSES THE
ICWA COMPONENT, BECAUSE THERE IS
AN EQUAL COMPONENT WHENEVER YOU
TOUCH CHILD WELFARE LAW. SO WITH
THAT, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS
BILL FOR THE GOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND JUST THANK HIM FOR
HIS CONSTANT GREAT WORK IN THIS
SPACE. AND TO ALL THE ADVOCATES,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ASHBY, SENATOR LAIRD, AND
SENATOR DIEGO. I WAS JUST GOING
TO MOVE THE BILL. OH, I'M SORRY,
SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR ASHBY'S
BEATING YOU TO IT. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR NIHILO. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
REASON FOR THIS LEGISLATION,
ORIGINALLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL,
AND I'M TOTALLY SYMPATHETIC TO
IT. BUT THERE'S ONE CONCERN THAT
I HAVE THROUGH SIDE DISCUSSIONS
THAT I'VE HAD THAT MAYBE I'M
MISINTERPRETING IT, BUT,
JUVENILE, FOSTER CARE, JUDICIAL
SYSTEM IS FOUNDED ON THE PREMISE
THAT THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN IS
THE INTEREST OF THE CHILD. AND
MY CONCERN ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
LAW IS THAT THAT SPECIFIC
INTEREST IS, IN APPEARS TO ME
SUBJUGATED TO THE PRIORITY OF
THE TRIBE INTERESTS. HOW DO YOU
ANSWER THAT? IT'S DIRECTLY TO
THE INTEREST OF THE CHILD. AND
THAT WAS PART OF THE ARGUMENT
WITH HOLLAND VERSUS BRACKEN,
WHERE THE U.S SUPREME COURT
SIDED WITH INDIAN CHILDREN
BECAUSE OF THE ASSIMILATION
POLICIES THAT THE UNITED STATES
USED DURING COLONIZATION, TRYING
TO STRIP CULTURE, LANGUAGE THAT
ICWA WAS CREATED TO THEN PUT THE
TRIBAL KIDS BACK WITH TRIBAL
FAMILIES AND TRIBAL CULTURE TO
RETAIN THAT CULTURE MOVING
FORWARD. SO THE ARGUMENT THAT
YOU'RE BRINGING UP WAS WHAT WAS
DEBATED AT THE US SUPREME COURT
THAT ENDED UP ON A 7 TO 2
RULING, SIDING WITH INDIAN
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO BE PLACED
WITH CULTURE AND TRADITIONS BACK
WITH THE FAMILIES. SO IT IS THE
INTEREST OF THE CHILD TO BE
BACK, TO LEARN THE CULTURE OF
WHAT'S BEEN RUNNING THROUGH
THEIR ANCESTRAL LINES. MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT CASE IS
THAT THAT ADOPTION WAS WHAT WAS
PREFERRED BY THE PARENTS WHO HAD
THE LINK TO, NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE, AND THAT THE CHILD WAS
WITH THE ADOPTED FAMILY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND THEN TAKEN OUT
OF THE ADOPTED FAMILY. I
UNDERSTAND THE REASON, BUT I
JUST QUESTION WHETHER THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN. WELL, THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE PLACEMENT,
THOUGH. IT'S SOMEWHAT, I GUESS,
STICKY SINCE THE PARENTS
PREFERRED THAT ADOPTION, BUT
NONETHELESS THE TO HAVE THE
CHILD WITH THAT ADOPTED FAMILY
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND THEN TAKE
THEM OUT OF THAT, WHAT APPEARED
BY ALL CASES TO BE A HAPPY
ENVIRONMENT. MIGHT HAVE
OVERRIDDEN THE INTEREST OF THE
CHILD. AND THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS WHAT WHAT WHAT IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN ONE PARENT, IS, OF
NATIVE, NATIVE AMERICAN DESCENT
AND ONE PARENT IS NOT, AND IT
ENDS UP WITH A FOSTER CHILD.
WHAT HAPPENS? AND SO THERE'S TWO
ISSUES THERE. YEAH. I'M NOT SURE
IF THOSE WANT TO ADDRESS THAT
COMPONENT OF IT, BUT IT GOES
BACK TO THE TO THE TRIBE THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL IS FROM, TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK AND TO BE PLACED
TO LEARN THAT CULTURE AND TO
KEEP THAT CULTURE MOVING
FORWARD. THE BRACKEN CASE,
HOLLAND VERSUS BRACKEN, BROUGHT
UP THOSE POINTS, AND THAT WAS
DEBATED AT THE US SUPREME COURT,
WHERE THE U.S SUPREME COURT
SIDED WITH THE INTERESTS OF THE
CHILD TO BE ABLE TO RETAIN THE
CULTURE THAT WAS STRIPPED DURING
ASSIMILATION POLICIES. ICWA IS A
RARE INSTANCE OF REVERSE
ASSIMILATION, REVERSE
ASSIMILATION, BRINGING BACK THE
CULTURE THAT WAS STRIPPED FROM
THE CHILD FROM THE BEGINNING. SO
THAT GOES BACK INTO THOSE AREAS
AS FAR AS WHEN YOU HAVE A PARENT
THAT'S OF NATIVE AMERICAN AND
ANOTHER ONE THAT'S NOT, THAT
WOULD BE UP TO THE COURTS TO
INTERPRET. THAT'S WHAT ICWA IS
ABOUT. ALRIGHTY, SENATOR WAHAB,
ARE YOU FINISHED? SENATOR
YELLOW? OKAY. SENATOR WAHAB,
THERE MAY BE A RESPONSE TO ONE.
THERE MAY BE A RESPONSE TO ONE
QUESTION THAT I ASKED. I'M
SORRY, I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
THAT ICWA DOES NOT SUPPLANT THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD
STANDARD IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. ICWA ENSURES THAT
CULTURE AND COMMUNITY BECOMES A
COMPONENT AND IS CONSIDERED IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD.
TRIBES LONG TRIBES. HISTORY. IF
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
OCCURRED THERE WERE CHILDREN
FORCIBLY REMOVED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES TO BREAK THE CULTURE,
TO DISASSEMBLE TRIBES AND THE
CONTINUITY OF OUR CULTURE. AND
THIS WAS THE FIX TO IT. SO YOU
CAN'T NOT CONSIDER THAT. BUT
AGAIN, IT DOESN'T REPLACE OR
REMOVE THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD. STANDARD CONSIDERATIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE SYSTEM.
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SO THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS UP, I'M GLAD THAT
YOU REPRESENT YOUR COMMUNITY
VERY WELL, PRIMARILY, YOU HAVE
BROUGHT UP A NUMBER OF BILLS
REGARDING THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT, I MYSELF AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH, RIGHT. SO I
FULLY UNDERSTAND EXACTLY THE
SYSTEM AND THE FAILURES, I THINK
IT WAS ALSO STATED, YOU KNOW, WE
HEAR IN THE HISTORY BOOKS AND WE
READ IT THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE,
LET'S SAY DURING EVEN SLAVERY
TIME. RIGHT? THEY WOULD BREAK UP
THE NUCLEUS FAMILY SPECIFICALLY
TO REMOVE CULTURE, REMOVE
LANGUAGE, REMOVE RELIGION,
REMOVE ANY IDENTITY, AND THAT
WAS DONE ALSO MORE RECENTLY TO
NATIVE AMERICANS AND OTHER
CULTURES AS WELL, IN WEIRD LEGAL
WAYS. RIGHT, SO I REALLY RESPECT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE, AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, CONFLATE KIND OF WHAT'S
GOING ON, IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND SPECIFICALLY IN ANY
SITUATION THAT'S SET UP FOR
CHILDREN, THE PRIORITY IS THE
CHILD. FIRST AND FOREMOST. I
WILL SAY THAT TO ME, IT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY MATTER WHAT ETHNIC
BACKGROUND PER SE. I JUST WANT A
HAPPY, HEALTHY, SAFE HOME FOR
THE CHILD, THAT'S FIRST AND
FOREMOST. AND I THINK ANY JUDGE,
ANY SOCIAL WORKER, ANY PERSON
THAT IS WORKING ON A CHILD'S
CASE PRIORITIZES FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THE SECOND PIECE IS
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE, RIGHT?
MAKING SURE THAT, HEY, CAN WE
ENSURE THAT WHETHER IT'S
LANGUAGE, RELIGION, CULTURE,
FOOD, YOU KNOW, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE RESPECTED, RIGHT? AND
WE HAVE TO GO FURTHER WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MORE DIVERSE AND
MINORITY AMONGST MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. THAT WAS A
REQUIREMENT AND A REQUEST THAT
I'VE SEEN HISTORICALLY BEING
DONE IN OTHER COMMUNITIES. SO
I'M HOPING THAT WE HAVE THE SAME
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS AS WELL.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, WHEN WE
SEE THIS, I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
WHY THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT
AND ALSO VERY INTERESTING. THERE
WAS AN INDIVIDUAL THAT I ENGAGED
WITH THAT WAS ADOPTED, AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE DID NOT VIEW THEM AS
THEIR EQUAL BECAUSE THIS PERSON
WAS ADOPTED BY TWO WHITE
PARENTS. AND IDENTIFIED AS WHITE,
BUT ETHNICALLY AND BIOLOGICALLY
WAS MEXICAN. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM IS
LARGELY PEOPLE OF COLOR, WITH
LESS AND LESS PEOPLE BEING ABLE
TO ADOPT THEM THAT ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. RIGHT. AND SO THERE ARE
SOME DEVIATIONS THERE. AND, YOU
KNOW, THERE WAS A HARD
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE REST OF
THEIR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS TO
WHY DOES THIS PERSON IDENTIFY AS
WHITE WHEN VISIBLY THEY ARE NOT
WHITE? RIGHT. AND SO THERE ARE
SOME CULTURAL CONFLICTS THERE.
BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW, IT TAKES A
LOT OF THERAPY. YOU KNOW, JUST
JUST BEING IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM, PEOPLE PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS. THIS IS MORE
THAN JUST YOU KNOW, LIKE SOME
SOME NEWS SITUATION OR, YOU
KNOW, SOCIAL MEDIA POST. IT'S
PEOPLE'S LIVES, PEOPLE'S
IDENTITIES, ESPECIALLY IF THEY
GREW UP IN THAT. SO BEING ABLE
TO PROTECT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURE AND THE IDENTITY OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, MY QUESTION IS IF
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH HOMES RIGHT,
PLACEMENT TO OTHER LOVING
FAMILIES WOULD BE AN OPTION,
CORRECT? FAMILY COALITION. YES
RIGHT. WHOA WHOA WHOA. OKAY I
THINK I THINK SOME RAMOS
ANSWERED. YES. RIGHT. DID YOU
WANT DID YOU WANT YOUR WITNESS
TO RESPOND? I WANTED TO SEE IF
THEY WANT TO ADDRESS, BECAUSE
THERE ARE LINES ON. OKAY. YES.
OKAY. OKAY. THANK YOU. AND I
JUST WANT TO WITH CHAIR'S
PERMISSION, JUST ASK A COUPLE
MORE QUESTIONS. SO YOU GUYS
WOULD PRIORITIZE WITH THIS BILL
IN PLACE? ONE, THE CHILD'S
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING, FIRST AND
FOREMOST. CORRECT. THERE THERE
ARE PLACEMENT PREFERENCES AND A
PRIORITY TO TRY TO KEEP THE
CULTURE CONNECTED. YES, BUT THE
BENEFIT, AGAIN, IT IS NOT
REPLACING THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD 100%. RIGHT. SO NUMBER
ONE IS THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD HEALTH, WELL-BEING. YOU
KNOW, EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
SAFETY AND SECURITY. CORRECT
THERE. YES, THERE THERE ARE ALSO
THERE ALSO PREFERENCES TO
CONNECT THE CULTURE, KEEP THE
CULTURE CONNECTED OKAY. AND IF
THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE, WHICH.
YEAH, EVERYBODY I THINK IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IT'D BE IDEAL
TO HAVE A FAMILY THAT'S PART OF
THAT CHILD'S. OKAY. AND IS THERE
ANY DATA POINTS THAT THIS IS
BEING TRACKED AND THE SUCCESS
AND THE WELL-BEING OF THAT CHILD
LONG TERM? YES. THERE'S
ACTUALLY, THERE ARE THERE IS A
GROWING BODY OF DATA BEING
COLLECTED, AND I DON'T HAVE IT
ON ME, BUT CAN CERTAINLY SUPPLY
IT TO THE COMMITTEE FOLLOWING
THIS HEARING. OKAY. AND THIS IS
ALSO I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
FOR FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES.
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
FEDERALLY AND THEN CALIFORNIA
COMPONENTS IS WHAT WE'RE
ADOPTING INTO IT TO ENSURE THAT
MOVING FORWARD. OKAY, I KNOW YOU
AND I HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE SMALLER TRIBES FEDERAL
LAW, MR. CHAIR, JUST SURE. GO
AHEAD. THE PL 280 BILL WAS ALSO
A FEDERAL LAW. PL 280. SO THIS
DEALS WITH INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
ACT, A FEDERAL LAW. BUT NOW
WE'RE BRINGING CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY STRENGTHENING IT UP.
BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, IF
A CHILD IS IN FOSTER CARE AND
MOVING FORWARD, THE FIRST
PREFERENCE IS TO PUT THEM BACK
WITH THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. IF
THAT'S NOT THERE, THEN THE
INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT STAY IN
FOSTER CARE. IF THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THEM
FORWARD. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB,
NOT SEEING ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SENATOR ASHBY HAS
MOVED THE BILL, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS,
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
SENATORS FOR THEIR CONVERSATIONS.
DEFINITELY, DEEPLY APPRECIATE
IT. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL.
AND AGAIN, THIS STARTS TO
REVERSE ASSIMILATION POLICIES
AGAINST NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOT ONLY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, BUT ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
ASHBY. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 81. THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. UMBERG A UMBERG.
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO DURAZO. BARRASSO. AYE.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. MILO ROTH.
STERN. STERN. AYE WAHAB. WAHHAB.
AYE YOU HAVE 8 TO 0 WITH
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT. THERE ARE
TWO MEMBERS THAT AREN'T PRESENT.
AND SO THIS BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT OF COMMITTEE
AND ADVANCE TO THE FLOOR. BUT
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN HERE JUST FOR A LITTLE
WHILE, TO ALLOW THE OTHER TWO
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. SO ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. TOM.
ALL RIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY, IF
YOU WOULD OPEN THE ROLL,
CABALLERO. MILO. ROTH. ROTH.
ROTH AYE. ALL RIGHT, THAT
CONCLUDES 9 TO 0. 9 TO 0. THE
BILL IS OUT THAT CONCLUDES THE
HEARING. WE ARE ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU.